hello both of you I know yo i'm also a
creative director here in the US after
I've seen studio actually working on
Steve the stitching is extremely excited
with the your enthusiasm that we saw
from the beta phase lots of players
coming and find firm escapism adrenaline
and with the season pass we really want
to push this even further from day one
with the season pass to clear we get
access to a pile of exclusive content
including the Snowman Christian and also
a pack of helicopter tickets that we let
the player pretty much spoon anywhere in
the world it will let you even further
explore the world that we are delivering
in see when you're right and stick a
bottle o clock in the adrenaline pack
you can add access to new outfits and
new costumes for you to choose you
probably know that and still you can
ride at night the a donor impact will
come in new challenges and lifetime and
New York streets for you to shine under
the moon with the loser face covering
some even funnier questions like the
small like the banana lots of new
content here that in common that we're
really pleased if another question we
are also bringing one new super idea and
super fun discipline which is the sled
then we're going to add the extreme pack
the extreme pack is all about raising
the bar even more come with three new
sports the first one being base jump
it's all about free falling the second
one is rocket wings is really fast
exhilarating and Danvers and the last
one is big colliding you're going to fly
much faster so that's it for our season
pass I hope you love it season pass
comes with extreme or pure fun it's
going to be up to you the creative and
see what you guys want to do with in our
mountains see you up there